[music playing]
JIM SHEDD: Gilberto Rogriuez
Orejuela and Miguel Rodriguez
Orejuela were the
heads of a cartel
that was totally different
than the other cartels.
They looked at it more
as a business to expand,
and they were involved in
the cost versus profit.
You have to learn who your
enemy is, otherwise you're
not going to win the fight.
And I , studied over
a long period of time,
the Rodriguez Orejuelas,
and they were very smart,
strategic thinkers
who were always
one step ahead of the game.
NARRATOR: Gilberto
and Miguel Rodriguez
have a piece of
several hotels and own
Cali's largest shopping center.
NEWS ANNOUNCER: And they
own Cali's main passion,
the soccer team America.
JIM SHEDD: So, they
were to be respected.
Yes, they were dopers
and traffickers, but you
cannot underestimate them.
You underestimate people of
that caliber, you're doomed.
WILLIAM RODRIGUEZ: My
name is William Rodriguez.
I'm the son and nephew of the
Cali cartel founders, Miguel
and Gilberto Rodriguez Orejuela.
There was a strategic
alliance between my dad,
my uncle, and Escobar.
They had different ways
to see how we should fight
this war against authorities.
Escobar wanted to do
it through violence.
We wanted to do
it by corruption.
My dad Miguel was called
El Senor, the Sir.
My uncle Gilberto built
an economic empire.
He wanted to fulfill
his dream with my dad,
because he wanted my
dad to be a lawyer.
And that's why I
wanted to be a lawyer.
I want to be like my dad.
I wanted to help my family.
People think that bandits
don't have values.
But my dad and uncle did.
They have honor.
Violence was the last step
to resolve the problems,
because dead people
don't pay what they owe.
NARRATOR: Gilberto
Miguel Rodriquez
are forcing modern business
methods on a violent trade.
NARRATOR: The cartel forced
its employees to fill
out this application form.
Cartel hopefuls had to enter
the names and addresses
of their entire family.
JIM SHEDD: They had to know
who your family members were,
where were they, what
did they own, didn't own.
Cars, planes, automobiles,
trains, anything.
They had to know all
about you before you
were trusted into the system.
WILLIAM RODRIGUEZ: The
moving of the cocaine,
they did it by different ways.
First, they did it into little
planes into the Caribbean
and in Central America.
Then they shifted in to
doing it through Mexico.
NARRATOR: To handle the ever
larger shipments of cocaine
heading to the United
States, the cartel
used container ships,
sometimes even loading
up entire passenger jets.
NARRATOR: It is a
marriage of convenience
between Colombia's Cali
cartel and the Italian mafia.
When the Cold War
ended, a new war began.
NARRATOR: The problem
of cocaine in Russia
began only one or two years ago.
Cocaine is a new problem for us.
NARRATOR: From Moscow to
Madrid, from Rome to Tokyo,
the Cali cartel is
creating new markets.
NARRATOR: In raw
profit, it now outstrips
Boeing, Texaco, and Pepsi.
WILLIAM RODRIGUEZ: They had so
much power in those moments,
they thought they were
on the top of the world.
JIM SHEDD: They were
planning to eventually become
the Kennedys of Colombia.
WILLIAM RODRIGUEZ: In
the narcos cassettes,
you can see the power that
Miguel and Gilberto had,
because this guy is
saying you have the future
of Colombia in your hands.
If you give this money,
you will have a President.